hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
an eccentric high-flying businessman a
civil war politics a timeless car FBI
agents a multimillion-dollar drug bust
glamour Fame and a meteoric downfall
it's one of the most incredible stories
of modern times this is the story of
John DeLorean and his dmc-12 car a
unique car with a stainless steel
exterior gullwing doors and a cost of
four hundred million u.s. dollars to
produce all to become a strange
combination of a laughing stock and a
cultural icon John wanted to be the next
Enzo Ferrari or Ferdinand Porsche and he
would move heaven and earth to make it
happen even if it cost him everything
you are watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
John DeLorean was the Elon Musk of the
early 1980s his high-profile management
of General Motors Pontiac and Chevrolet
divisions saw him quickly rise up the
corporate ladder in a time when
executives were dull and conservative
John DeLorean was one of the first hyper
successful people in the corporate world
to exhibit an eccentric life while at
General Motors in the 1960s he
demonstrated his engineering talent and
quickly rose to manage the Pontiac
division at just age 40 he was the
youngest to do so john turned Pontiac
from a grandmother's brand for older
buyers to a muscle car by leading the
legendary Pontiac GTO project it was a
risky move to put such a large engine in
such a small car and upper management
were mortified at the gamble paid off
the Pontiac GTO went on to influence the
American muscle car movement his next
project the Pontiac Firebird was also an
all-time classic less than a decade
later he became the youngest ever vice
president of General Motors the largest
corporation in the world at the time his
jet black hair paired with unbuttoned
shirts often violated almost all of the
company's dress codes but made him a
charismatic figure in a sea of bland
corporatism he was a multi-millionaire
charming capable of influencing people
and even played the jazz saxophone
during his meteoric rise he was dating
what would be his third wife world top
fashion model
Christina Ferrer John first saw her on
the cover of Vogue magazine later he
would make his own high profile
appearances and magazines General Motors
hated the press attention as it didn't
suit their image but they couldn't
complain because John's sales numbers
were making them a ton of money
John was in Lyon to become the president
of the biggest corporation in the world
but instead he chose to give a press
speech highlighting the company's flaws
and publicly outing executives General
Motors wasn't happy and he was forced
out of the company
but this didn't face John was it true
that no one liked you there John oh I
think no I think I got along with most
of the people pretty well although there
are a few you know everybody in every
organization has some people on your
side and some against he would leave to
build his own car company a feat that
was thought to be impossible at the time
it hadn't been done in America since
Chrysler in the 1920s he was a risk
taker a valuable asset that would
eventually lead to his downfall it would
end with him sitting in an LA hotel with
27 kilograms of cocaine and FBI agents
in the room next door but that comes
later on in the story john delorean
starting his own company would begin one
of the wildest rides in automotive
history by 1973 DeLorean would break the
restraint of corporate life at GM with
little more than some drawings on the
back of an envelope his plan was to
start his own company called the
DeLorean Motor Company or DMC his dream
of an eco-friendly rust-proof sports car
available to the masses manifested
itself in the now famous DeLorean dmc-12
car the stainless steel body and hard
lines were designed by legendary geo
ghetto guy Gary oh the Italian designer
had worked on everything from Ferraris
to the Ford Mustang it's going doors
added to its unrivaled vision of the
future it looks as striking today as it
did when it was being designed back in
the late 1970s in the movie Back to the
Future Marty McFly used the decked out
version of the DeLorean to transport
back in time the films helped to
immortalize that DeLorean in order to
realize his vision John needed financial
backing he raised over seventeen million
through his old automotive contacts but
he still needed much more then John had
a brilliant idea
he bypassed the traditional methods of
raising money and went straight to
governments of regions with high
unemployment a very smart move Northern
Ireland at the time was the perfect
opportunity we went to Belfast because
no one else would have us in the world
everybody said it's inconceivable that
in today's day that any new automobile
company could survive it's not possible
we did give you the money so we went to
Belfast because nobody else would go to
Bell
during the late 1970s Belfast the
capital of Northern Ireland was going
through conflicts over breaking off from
the UK and religious tensions were also
high street violence bombings and
assassinations were the norm
unemployment was high at 33 percent an
investment was almost non-existent while
most people saw this as a deterrent
John DeLorean saw an opportunity in 1978
he would set up a factory against a
backdrop of bombs and violence with the
UK government bankrolling him the whole
way they were just happy to see jobs
being created as were the people of
Belfast can you hope to justify the huge
amount of government money that's gone
into DeLorean Lorien has repeatedly said
that he helps very soon we're able to
buy the government out instead we saw
that money will return to the government
and of course the arrangements provide
that the government gets a royalty on
every car so if the production it comes
up to schedule if the sales are as mr.
Lorient and his people think that they
will be then the thing will be a success
and the government will be as pleased as
anybody the DeLorean Factory was
state-of-the-art with new production
processes that had never been tried
before at the time while there was no
shortage of applications there was a
shortage of skills people who had never
built a car before were thrown onto the
assembly line but surprisingly for the
most part the two sides who had fought
each other on the streets worked side by
side on the factory floor DeLoreans
brazen move to the troubled Northern
Ireland was a masterstroke at the time
orders of John DeLoreans cars came
rolling in over 30,000 before production
had even began his experience in the
automotive industry was a huge brand
advantage
mr. DeLorean they tell me that you're
the best salesman in the world if I came
to you how would you sell me one of your
cars very proud of our car which
essentially I think is is a major
engineering contribution to the state of
the art of automobiles I'd sell it to
you on the basis that it's a very
comfortable outstanding performance
outstanding handling in the end we hope
that your cost of owning this car for a
long
time will be very very small the
DeLorean slogan was lived the dream and
people bought into that dream consumer
demand was so high that dealerships were
turning people away as others slept down
5,000 and cash as a deposit just to get
in Lyon the number of people's we could
attract who said can I leave a deposit
for the car and we said no we're not
taking any more deposits it got to such
a point Isis the only way we'll take you
to Pilate is five thousand cash and
don't bug me the marketing campaign was
spearheaded by the charismatic John
DeLorean he raised a lot of hype much
like Elon Musk is doing now the car was
so famous that even whiskey brands
featured the DeLorean car to sell their
whiskey despite the glamour the factory
was in the middle of a literal warzone
there were fire bombings bullet holes
through windows and a manager's office
was burnt down as significant as these
events were this was the first problem
of many for John DeLorean as the dmc-12
began mass production many engineering
issues still remained with the car the
panels didn't always line up the going
doors proved difficult to consistently
replicate and the inexperienced to work
for us had difficulty producing the
number of cars and needed to stay afloat
normally at the time a new car model
would take about five years to design
they were going to do it all in 18
months and this was to earn enough money
to stay in business production problems
and time restraints saw many problems by
the final design parts from existing
cars had to be used in critically the
rear mounted engine wasn't powerful
enough for the increased weight so the
car ended up being slow with a 0 to 60
time of 10 seconds the car was
originally supposed to cost 30,000 US
dollars but it was now twice that
despite the problems in January of 1981
the first car rolled off the line the
factory workers were elated
they had overcome the problems of
political fighting and the killing
outside to come together and build
something special
the company was hemorrhaging money but
by the end of 1981 they managed to
increase production to 80 cars a day and
actually became profitable over 7,000
cars were produced by that point the
dealers just can't wait to get our
products I think the only thing we have
to do now is be sure that we do a very
professional job of building the car the
way it's supposed to and delivering it
looked like the DeLorean Motor Company
was going to make it despite all the
critics then disaster struck in the
United States a terrible blizzard hit
several states in the north it hit so
hard that it buried entire cities as a
result cities came to a standstill and
people couldn't get to work the economic
impact of this along with a general
recession meant that people weren't keen
or could afford to go out and buy a new
car especially a car like the DeLorean
dmc-12 demand dropped overnight and the
company having only just become
profitable was not in a place to weather
the storm as the workers at the Belfast
factory returned from their Christmas
break there was talk that there wasn't
enough money to pay the wages only 3,000
cars were ever sold soon
reality would hit and John DeLorean
would begin as he always did to try and
charm his way out of yet another problem
he said that he would fight for the
company until his last breath and what
he did next proved that he meant what he
said we worked too long and too hard to
let fuel elaborations father isn't it's
important that we really share public
credibility and reestablish our
relationship with the government on a
positive basis and never get any money
from the government now I think you'll
be very pleased with the news that
you'll hear tonight I can't tell you any
more about it right now John DeLorean
was on the hunt for a bailout to the
tune of 40 million dollars the UK
government by now had changed leadership
to Margaret Thatcher Thatcher was not a
fan of government subsidies so seeing
that the government had already forked
out millions to start the factory she
was unwilling to help
John was given a few months by the
government to find an investor or
declare bankruptcy
he took the dmc-12 to the new york car
show a promotional tour to conjure up
investor interest rumors circulated
about John DeLorean traveling to
billionaires in the US and oil sheiks in
the Middle East to try and find anyone
willing to invest but John DeLoreans
luck and charm had finally run out the
factory was closed in mid-1982 with only
a skeleton crew remaining 1,300 workers
had been laid off and only 9,000 cars
were ever made but the workers weren't
taking it with little to lose they
stormed the gates of the factory and
occupied in protest but no investors
meant that no one cared we're walking
out of the plant the last time today how
do you feel about it good nerdy
pretty upset what are your chances of
getting another job
what's the mood of the rest of the men
who haven't been paid off today how do
they feel about that as well they're
feeling very uneasy
uncertain their 13 week-long protests
were completely in vain one man however
did care and he was going to take any
means necessary to revive his company
now it's a lot of information as
surfaced really in recent weeks that
would indicate and prove the fact that
the British government put us out of
business we didn't go out of business
for example a few months back when it
looked like my company was going to
start again the British government took
the body dies which is a single most
expensive and complex component of our
car and they took him out in the middle
of Galway Bay and threw him in the ocean
and the man who was trying to buy him
from Columbus Ohio Marvin Katz said a
scuba diver down with a strobe light and
sure as shootin there they are laying on
the ocean floor DeLorean Motor Cars
Belfast Northern Ireland 18 million
dollars worth of the most beautiful dyes
you've ever seen and of course do you
want any proof of conspiracy I think
that does it having been rejected by
seemingly every investor in the world
John DeLorean was desperate he stepped
into an elevator at a hotel near Los
Angeles International Airport
he surely must have been thinking that
this was his saving grace having just
arrived from New York he was going to
meet with Associates of his neighbor he
was going to discuss the deal that would
save his company John sat down in the
hotel room with his new associate he
thanked them for the opportunity which
to him was a godsend
as John gleamed with hope in his chair
27 kilograms of cocaine sat on the table
in front of him he had just agreed to
finance a cocaine deal for another
hundred kilos this would be worth a
whopping 67 million u.s. dollars he
would then use this money to revive his
company the thing was John thought that
he had outsmarted the dealers by giving
them worthless stock in his company that
was bankrupt and had no assets he was
going to get millions and no cost to
himself several minutes later the tides
turned as all of the men in the hotel
room were toasting to their successful
endeavors two FBI agents let themselves
in it was a sting operation
they put John in handcuffs under arrest
for conspiracy to obtain and distribute
67 million dollars worth of cocaine the
footage was damning and with John in
handcuffs
the DeLorean dream was over in a matter
of just 12 months John DeLorean had gone
from the top of the world to facing
serious jail time good evening this is
the CBS Evening News dan Rather
recording it's a story of big business
big pressure big money and the crime of
cocaine it's the story of how and why
the FBI caught automaker John Z DeLorean
when the DeLorean car first rolled out
of the factory in Ireland last year much
of America was rooting for its success
its creator former General Motors
executive John DeLorean had thumbed his
nose at the big automakers saying he'd
show the industry how to build cars
Lorien subsequent meetings with the
dealers were then videotapes by federal
authorities who finally arrested him
earlier this week the question of
entrapment whether John DeLorean was
unlawfully lured by federal agents into
committing a crime is one strategy
DeLoreans new attorney will have to
tackle although experts say it is not
likely to work a loan broker in
Cleveland was on the verge of approving
a 200 million dollar loan that could
have saved a lorian's company Bible
classifies pride is the deadliest sin
and it is I freely accept the
responsibility my my arrogance and my
gigantic ego got me in a lot of trouble
when the British government refused to
support my business if I were a normal
rational guy would have said if they
don't want it I don't want it and I
should have taken a walk and gotten
another job instead because that car had
my name on it I was gonna fight it out
to the end and as a consequence I had to
be broken and Here I am DeLorean had his
fair share of bad luck over the past
year but he found himself on the right
side of the coin this time in 1984
miraculously after a 22 week trial the
jury found him not guilty on all
accounts ruling that the FBI had
entrapped DeLorean the jury saw it as a
desperate attempt of a man who was
willing to do anything to save his
company and a government that took
advantage of that fact this was seen as
the case because of President Reagan's
recent war on drugs the prosecution of
DeLorean would have been a great
government PR stunt DeLorean walked out
of the court a free man but his company
was bankrupt and his reputation
tarnished a reporter asked if you would
go back into the order industry John
DeLorean replied I don't know would you
buy a used car from me life is a
hard-working industrialist has been
tattered and torn I don't know would you
buy a used car from me the rest of John
DeLoreans life was a shadow of his
former ambitions a few days after the
trial John's wife left him and
undoubtedly he had ruined his children's
lives he would pass away in 2005 in a
small one-bedroom apartment it was said
that he was planning sketches for his
next project when he had a heart attack
ultimately DeLorean Motor Company never
saw the light of day again
John was it always a dream to build your
own car I think it sort of came to me
one time and I was making the new car
announcement and we're telling the
dealers and the
like what a dramatic and miraculous new
car this was it really wasn't it was the
same old car with the fenders been a
little bit differently and so I thought
I just can't keep doing this and so I
decided to go off and try to do
something more ethical from the
standpoint of something that would last
and that's where the stainless steel car
concept came from but I've had the I had
the idea for a long time
John's life events had the hallmarks of
a blockbuster movie from vice-president
of the biggest corporation at the time
to civil war crime drugs and FBI agents
this was the story of a man who had a
dream the story of how far someone is
willing to go to make that lifelong
dream happen no matter what
John DeLorean bent the rules to try
something new
he pushed beyond what was thought to be
possible but his desperation and some
bad luck entered the DeLorean dream but
while it may all seem like a disaster
the cultural relevance of his car still
lives on today are you telling me you
built a time machine
DeLorean the way I see it if you're
gonna build a time machine into a car
why not do it from style it's
mind-boggling to think what would have
happened if another deal came through
and he made it
maybe DeLorean would have had enough
money to fix the teething problems of
the first car perhaps the DeLorean Motor
Company would be a revolutionary car
brand today I'm interested to know your
thoughts on this story leave your
comments below so anyway thanks for
watching my name is to gogo and you've
been watching cold fusion and if you did
enjoy this video feel free to subscribe
I think the next episode will be on me
so if you do want to get to know me a
bit better stick around for that all
right so I'll see you again soon for the
next video
cheers guys have a good one
Oh Tyrion are you thinking
[Music]